hey
here we are lagging once again yeah for
some reason
i don't know [ __ ] king and queens of
[ __ ]
black that whole show
last time lagged i know it started doing
that like the last few i don't know what
the [ __ ] is in there i'm gonna have to
like root around in there because i
don't think we're not doing another live
stream until saturday night
and the audio is shitty do you have yeah
it's on um and i even i tested it
in audacity like before we did it
because i didn't know if like the
if the microphone was going to hits up i
hope not but it sounded fine in
audacity so yeah we got more i don't
know if it's gonna be we can always use
the professional one
if we have to that's true even though
it's kind of yeah we'll just move it out
here because
yeah was for my audiobooks i have a
really nice like scarlet solo
like in there it's just kind of mounted
to the ceiling yeah so it's kind of hard
to like move
all right so uh before we get to
talking about the movie we're gonna
probably get a couple little shout outs
now the last five shirts that we had to
send out
or the last five packages of shirts we
just we mailed them today
so uh keep an eye out for those i think
two of them were going to england and
the rest of them were
domestic yeah so those are al so all the
shirts i think should be
out you know unless i don't know we'll
see how she
goes um also we wanted to thank sophie
once again
yeah is always sending us she's like the
she's like the female santa claus
so i said that in the comments yesterday
we got another movie we got back from
the post office and we found like
another little movie sitting on our
sitting on our little porch this is
sicario which i've actually
really been wanting to see this like for
a long time yeah there's two of those
and that they're both good
too so i'm very very excited to like uh
see that we have so many good movies
around to watch
yeah um so yeah so speaking of movies
this also has to do with sophie too
because remember yesterday
was it yesterday she sent us that movie
the voices with ryan reynolds from 2014
which is really good it's um
it's a horror comedy well about that is
that there was an
there's another movie that came out this
year called the voices
so i decided to review that one today
too because that was on toby
yeah and that's the thing like i said
yesterday because remember we reviewed
distiller yesterday
yeah yeah and i was kind of like oh
maybe
maybe tonight we'll watch uh you know
vikings versus krampus or something like
that but then for some reason like last
night i was like sometimes you're in a
mood for like kind of a shitty movie
like or a stupid movie and sometimes
you're not like last night i just really
wasn't
i was like i kind of want to watch
something that's kind of like
competently made and it's probably like
kind of more serious or like actually
kind of more a scary movie rather than
like a goofy one
so i picked this one hoping that i kind
of picked a couple and like watched the
first few minutes of them to like make
sure
i knew what i was getting into so this
one actually turned out like looked to
be the most interesting
and it seemed to me i went and just like
skimmed through like some other like
their star ratings and stuff like that
this doesn't seem to have gotten like
super awesome reviews but i really
really dug it it had good acting
yeah and interestingly when i looked it
up the the girl uh the woman that plays
the main character that played the main
character grace um amanda markowitz
she's been in like some other movies as
well
she actually got best actress at like
the hollywood indie film festival or
something like that for this movie
and um the woman that played her sister
victoria matlock
um she's actually i think she's better
known as a broadway actress
so there's some good acting chops in
this and there's like some people that
you will recognize
um lynn shea is in this like not she's
only like in a couple of scenes like
maybe five minutes um you know she was
in the garage and uh
insidious and stuff like that um also
[ __ ] uh what the [ __ ] is that dude's
name i can't remember what that actor's
name is but he was the guy that played
warren in empire records like i know
he's been in other [ __ ] too
because i've seen him in other movies
but he's in this too it's like kind of
like a really small part
but um he's in it so this
is a psychological
horror kind of like a psycho horror
thriller it's not yeah
more thriller than horror it's not gory
or nothing like that
normally normally uh not really uh
my genre uh but this was a well-made
movie
um i wouldn't take it over my other
favorite movies and other genres
but if you liked it if you like this
genre then you'll probably like this
movie
yeah i'm pretty good for some reason i
got like super into it so
the um yeah it's a jenny thing jenny
loves this guy
well no she would have different tastes
jenny jenny likes this kind of movie
i mean i like a lot i like a lot of
different kind of movies you know what i
mean like in the horror genre like
you know i'll watch pretty much anything
but um you know so this one the premise
of this one
is that there's this woman grace and i
guess
her fiance like he asked her to marry
him and then like almost immediately
like cheated on her and like
so and she caught him so she's
taking she's like a student i think
she's like um going for her master's
degree or a phd or something like that
in psychology
and so she's like well i need to get the
[ __ ] out of here like for christmas
break or winter break or whatever
and so she decides that she's going to
go up
and visit her sister catherine um who
she hasn't seen in a really long time
hold on one second what
somebody's asking where there's a link
where they can buy t-shirts um
you can um send me you should send
jenny a message or direct message on
facebook that's one way you can do it
you can also if you're in the
continental united states you can uh
send us a 20 super chat right now and
then send us your address and i'll send
it and what size you want right
and what design you want design and size
right because like i said and it might
take a while because i might have to
order more blanks like we do have some
blank like extra but i don't have like a
lot of different sizes
so i usually have somebody's size i
usually have to get them i order them
from jiffy shirts and they usually come
like in a day or two so it's right
a huge deal and we have like with the
screens already so we can like print
them pretty much so for 20
super chat you can buy the shirt send us
your information yeah
i mean we have a zazzle store which has
but like we it's not the same shirt
they're not the same shirts because we
have like different designs that we
screen printers these are better than
the dazzle shirts if you ask me they
last a lot longer
you know what's weird though it's like i
have a bunch of shirts that i made that
i ordered on the zazzle store and like
mine
um are fine yeah you've seen mine i know
yours is just like completely fell apart
and it's like i have a bunch of like i
have a satanic panic one i have my
um my dead ringers one i have like all
and they're and they're totally fine
i've watched them a bunch of times and
the
the gray infantry shirt that uh sophie
sent me with the cross rifles the cross
rifles are falling off already
that's really weird we're going to make
our own cross rifle shirt that's going
to be
show related i like that the design of
that shirt i'm going to make my own
version of that shirt
yeah 13 o'clock version i gotta do that
yeah yeah
actually you can get that clip art there
yeah cross rifles that's out there yeah
i mean like pretty much i can find
pretty much anything yeah
so you know yeah just depends on if i
can use it or not
but uh sandra said all the testosterone
washed it out
i guess it must have because it's like
mine mine are still fine i don't know
and i don't think i don't think that i
washed ears any more than i washed mine
right it was the same amount of time i
don't know what that was i don't know
but yeah so so she decides she's going
to go to this like
remote cabin where i guess they grew up
like with their family
and catherine has inherited she was the
older sister so she inherited this cabin
now grace is suspicious
that something something might be going
wrong with catherine because she hasn't
really heard from all that much she
thinks she's going
like super isolated up there um
something happened like her uh husband
apparently took her daughter away
because she thought she was like
going nuts or whatever and their mom
like a long time ago
was schizophrenic and committed suicide
and then there was a thing with their
dad and he like took off or he never got
over it or something
so when the this like i really really
liked like the build-up of this because
it's almost
entirely like there's a couple other
characters like in flashbacks and
whatnot
but pretty much the whole thing is just
these two women these two sisters
in this one cabin and like outside of
the cabin
and i love that i just kind of went into
this
blind so i didn't really know
what exactly was happening because it's
like everybody sort of had
like catherine was clearly
something was the matter with her you
know what i mean because like she'd be
normal
but then she was kind of real
standoffish and then like every now and
then the camera would tilt and then she
would just like say something like in a
normal tone of voice but it was just
like batshit crazy or it didn't make any
sense
and then like her sister be like what
the [ __ ] did you say and she's just like
uh
nothing everything's fine you know what
i mean so she's clearly like
losing her mind and then but then
there's like some [ __ ] that's happening
that maybe is paranormal and so
you don't know if it's like if the house
is haunted
or if the one sister's
craziness is rubbing off on the younger
sister or if the younger sister
also has the schizophrenia gene and it's
coming to fruition too
because there's a whole thing about the
mom being like you know she was fine and
then she got pregnant with the younger
daughter and then her schizophrenia
started to
like manifest and then the same thing
happened to catherine
so the younger sister who turns out is
also pregnant is like
afraid that she's getting the same thing
so it's like you don't
know if there's just like this weird
synergy like it's some like
the madness is rubbing off or the
[ __ ] [ __ ] could be haunted and
neither one of them is crazy
or something so it's like you don't
really know what's going on
and it's like i really really like the
way they built it up and they really
built up the relationship between these
two women and you didn't really know
what was happening and i will say that
i i sort of guess one thing but i was i
was kind of wrong about it
um and then it went in a direction that
i wasn't expecting but in a good way it
wasn't kind of like one of those things
like oh geez here we go it was just kind
of like that like oh
i wasn't expecting that to happen and
then i will say i'm not gonna spoil it
i'm not gonna spoil the ending or
anything like that but
i will say the ending was very abrupt
and very like shocking
but i was into it well it dropped its
nuts at the end yeah they're like this
is how this [ __ ] ended you're like oh
and then it was like credits and i was
like oh
[ __ ] i was like they [ __ ] went there
with it
i was like you know what i mean so i
really liked that they did that because
like
you know it's very hard particularly
horror movies horror novels everything
it's like really really hard
to stick the landing yeah but this one i
thought it was good because they didn't
like
puss out i guess they kind of just went
it was a bummer but it's like they
didn't like high impact in
yeah and i and i really like that about
it but like i said i was looking around
and you know the star ratings it looked
like it was just getting two two and a
half something like that
and i was like really it's like maybe i
don't know it's just
for some reason it's like as soon as i
started watching it i just got really
invested i guess because you know the
woman that plays
grace she just seemed really like
relatable like from the beginning i also
kind of like that
her character like she's going up to
visit her sister
i guess because she was worried about
her but she also kind of had a little
bit
of an ulterior motive i guess because
she was like working on her uh you know
thesis like for her psychology degree or
whatever
and i guess she almost wanted to like
use her sister as like a lab rat kind of
like maybe not in like that horrible
away
but she kind was kind of wanting to like
check it out and see what the [ __ ] was
going on with her because she hadn't
seen her in a long time
because she was like making videos about
yeah i think that she's doing this that
the other thing and she's getting upset
about it because it's her sister but
then she's like trying to be like all uh
objective about it
so i kind of like that too that she had
a little bit she was still likable
but i like that she had like a little
bit of an ulterior motive
for going up there as well okay let me
answer
okay yeah uh if you can't do super chat
we can do paypal payment
uh for shirts just contact us on
facebook or even instagram whatever and
just
we'll talk about what order you want
what your sizes are
and we can do payment through paypal
pound we'll send it out when it's ready
gonna take a couple days yeah to get to
get everything depending on what size
you have to order like i said
we have to order the shirt but then i
can shoot it and it'll be out because
like i said i got some i can't remember
what sizes i have i think i have more
women's
sizes left than men sizes yeah i think i
have some women small and i think all
the mediums are gone
i think all the mediums are gone because
i ordered a lot of mediums because you
always get me and real big stuff we
gotta order too
um we also also have a new one want to
announce that we have a new one coming
a new design we just thought of it today
i want a tyrell corporation shirt it's
gonna and it's gonna [ __ ] have like a
really cool corporate logo and it's
gonna say tyrell
corporation replicants more human than
human
and it might have some japanese [ __ ]
uh
script on it too it's gonna it's gonna
look really cool it's gonna be a blanket
a blade runner themed thai rail
corporation sure to match
the other [ __ ] you know whale and
yutani and weyland corporation
so you know i'm going to hit up the
[ __ ] um
the [ __ ] what's his name universe
what's his [ __ ] name oh [ __ ]
dude who did the first alien and blade
runner ridley scott ridley scott
universe
all the ridley scott stuff
maybe i'll do a a colonial marine shirt
yeah that would be good be all you can
be colonial marines that kind of should
be good too yeah yeah [ __ ]
and because you know have one of their
[ __ ] colonial marines motivational
shirt
yeah like what they use for recruitment
and [ __ ] jogging because we had them
in the army so
they would have had them too unit-based
shirts yeah
maybe for that unit i gotta find out
what that unit was
that went down to lv426 maybe that
it's probably mentioned somewhere in the
expanded universe i'll make up their
unit shirt
yeah yeah probably have skull on it
skull and with [ __ ] cross rifles or
something
yeah some kind of mechanized infantry
shirt yeah karen asked if i had seen
late phases on shutter i have i think
that's the one with like the older guy
and he's like in that
like um retirement neighborhood and then
there's werewolves yeah it was
i think it was a werewolf movie yeah
that was actually really really good if
it's the same one i'm thinking of so i'm
pretty sure i've seen that one
and then somebody asked uh i think you
should cover
let the right one in and compare it to
the crap remake i actually
didn't mind the remake i mean obviously
the original one is much
much much better but the american one
wasn't
as bad as i was expecting i still have
to read the book though it's like that's
one of the ones that's kind of on my
list and i've seen it recommended on a
lot of like horror book channels
so one of these days i'll kind of get
around to it if it was like swedish or
something like that so it's like a
translation somebody's asking for a
hudson shirt
i would rather have like a platoon level
or a [ __ ] company level shirt from
their unit that they would have worn
you know what i mean while they were on
a [ __ ] company run or something yeah
because that's what we had they
basically weren't
they weren't they didn't go out of
uniform from what i saw in the movie
they did add some accessories some
people were wearing cutoffs
like they cut the sleeves off their
shirts to make a tank top
and then some of them had sleeves
depending on but that's the only mod i
just
but they weren't wearing what we used to
call you know hula shirts or
motivational shirts
each platoon had a custom shirt made
that we wore them
on runs went for a pt in the morning if
you're
in a high-speed unit you know i still
got some i got assassin's shirt i'll
show it
okay first three two seven assassins
yeah yeah [ __ ] that was the name of
our platoon
they all had [ __ ] corny names
mavericks assassins bulldogs that's all
that [ __ ]
same ones over and over again the jets
the sharks
it's all the [ __ ] same [ __ ]
generic [ __ ]
because if they let them do whatever
they wanted to do it'd be from [ __ ]
raunchy ass [ __ ] you know what i mean
well yeah yeah the butthorkers [ __ ] like
that
yeah hi we're the prolapsed stain this
is
yeah yeah what is
it would be some [ __ ] that would be
funny you know and they would
company commander wouldn't allow it you
can't leave people to their own devices
because when i was in high school my
senior year of high school i don't know
if they still do this or not
but they let all the seniors vote
on what your class flower was going to
be and all that kind of [ __ ]
so there people want to vote on what the
class song is going to be do you know
what got the most votes to
me so horny yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
and that got the most votes
but they wouldn't allow that they were
like no
[Laughter]
they picked one for us and it wasn't
even from the year that we graduated
which was 1990. they picked one from
like
god what did let the good times roll
that cars song
which wasn't even from 1990. it was like
from [ __ ] 1978 or some [ __ ]
colonel kurtz colonel kurtz from
apocalypse now called it he said he said
uh men men order boys to drop
fire on children from their airplanes
but they won't allow them to write
[ __ ] on the nose of the airplanes
because it's immoral
yeah that never made any sense didn't
make any sense when we were there either
well it's just kind of like funny to me
how some people
like get on not so much anymore but like
every now and then i'd get like some
comments complaining about how much we
swear yeah
and i'm like so we're talking about
serial killers that like
murder children and stuff like that and
you're worried about me
saying [ __ ] yeah yeah your
priorities
are really messed up you might want to
check off this channel
this channel was rated r from the very
very beginning well i like it just the
subject matter
look i can't stop swearing it's just i
just can't it's like the thing about it
is that i was raised by
um prolific swearers from my grandmother
on down
and it's like that's just how we talk i
just can't
if i try to like you know every now and
then like if i'm with a friend that's
like with a kid or something like that
and i try to not swear it's
really really hard i just can't i don't
know why
and it doesn't mean and actually you
know some people say oh you know
vocabulary isn't big and that's why you
swear and [ __ ] like that that is
[ __ ] because every study that
they've done
shows that the more intelligent people
swear more
so yeah maybe so
is that it for today um somebody asked
oh uh mango badger said he saw
two really good documentaries one was
about uh the guy that was in flash
gordon
called life after flash i think he said
and then there was one about stanley
kubrick
too so where did you see those because i
kind of want to see both of those
yeah and then he's and then he also said
later he said swearing is cool and [ __ ]
those cuts you don't like
it i love flash gordon man that movie i
thought that movie
it was a great response to star wars
when i was a kid
it was [ __ ] crazy it was like
watching a damn acid trip and it was
star wars but it was sexy
it has sex and drugs in it which the
original [ __ ] flash gordon had that
in it
before all the hays codes yeah that was
like super smart i was like
i was like surprised like seeing the
[ __ ] i mean you know it's not it's tame
by today's standards but like for
the time that it came out which is kind
of like the 20s and the 30s it was
[ __ ] half naked scantily clad dancers
dressed up in basically bikinis or slave
girl outfits and [ __ ] satanic statues
and ming and you know the budget was low
it was a low budget well yeah all those
cereals they all work like that
but they were really trying to put forth
a pretty good
product for for the time you know yeah
it was in a time when
science fiction was bottom of the barrel
you know what i mean
but at least they were trying with
[ __ ] flash gordon
yeah buck rogers too i think that was
the buck rogers was the [ __ ] flash
gordon knight so you're saying butt
rogers
so that's the foreign version yeah i
mean it's gotta be right yeah it's gotta
be
they did a good job [ __ ] recreating
that movie
the only thing that was wrong with it is
uh
the guy who played flash walked off the
[ __ ] set about halfway through it
and uh so that's how i understood how it
went [ __ ]
or or and actually i don't think that's
exactly what happened they needed him to
do voiceovers
and i don't think that that's his voice
somebody might might correct me it's
been a long time
but um and they just made up the ending
they were kind of
in the italian style of making that
movie up as they go
like you're saying [ __ ] weird when
you think of it it'll make sense later
they just kind of end
even if it doesn't [ __ ] it yeah well the
movie was going over budget and a lot of
the budget got
spent on those costumes and the cost
fantastic though
they only look good on blu-ray and on
film they looked
[ __ ] on [ __ ] vhs and television
because everything
looked like [ __ ] it wasn't enough to to
really illustrate what those costumes
how high quality those second costumes
were yeah he said it wasn't his voice he
said that was a
documentary yeah that's right well i
don't i think it wasn't his voice
you're right um i just kind of remember
that
and i think he left almost halfway
through it
yeah had to do with some kind of a they
were [ __ ] arguing over the price what
what you know how much he was supposed
to be paid i mean i would have thought
all that [ __ ] was established like from
the get-go like before you even start
working well you know how the italians
are they just keep going and going and
going and i think that's what what the
deal was is they were just
like after a while they're just like
what do you mean we gave you fifty
dollars yeah
you know what was going on for like
eight months worth of work
and uh what are you complaining about i
guess
i think cocaine was involved it would
think some cocaine wasn't fake
it was back in those days cocaine was
involved with that yeah
and he's like [ __ ] i ain't working it
anymore i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean where's my [ __ ]
money and i want more money
and i'm going to be a big star and he
walked off and never made another movie
that always makes me feel bad though
when that happens because it's like
i always feel for some reason i just
always feel really bad
about a person because you know that
it's like that was like their burning
passion like to be an actor or whatever
and then they're like in a movie and you
they think it's gonna be like the big
break
and it's like and then it comes out and
the movie just it sucks
or you know or even if it doesn't suck
even if it's really good like nobody
sees it or nobody gives a [ __ ] about it
it's like and then they never make a
movie ever again and it's like that just
bums me out of really a lot
dino de laurentiis studios made for me
made [ __ ] three
great movies conan one dune and flash
gordon
and and to me they that just completed
my [ __ ] childhood i [ __ ] loved
those
like my life it's like damn although
really objectively the only one that was
great
was conan one and that was [ __ ]
milius you know
john milius and i still love the score
for that yeah that's one of the few
movies that i would actually like by the
score and the score
the script direction the filmography
everything conan wonders a damn near
perfect movie
it that's the prehistoric star wars what
it was
yeah i love it yeah hell yeah salsa doom
was the prehistoric darth vader it's
even played by the same guy
[ __ ] yeah it's the same dude you know
and he turns into a snake i mean you
know he turns into a snake
and he's an army ranger in both of them
[ __ ] a lot of people don't know that
but james
jones was an army [ __ ] ranger he was
indeed yes he was
he started [ __ ] doing started off
doing military role
doing doing doing military roles you
know uh doctor strangelove
yeah he's one of the bomber crewmen
doctor straight i need to see that again
15 years and then uh you know
dune and flash gordon were supposed to
be responses to star wars
and in some ways they were better than
star wars but they just didn't have the
[ __ ] edit and the excitement and the
timing and i think
i feel like editors are some of the most
underrated people
in the movie making business yeah i mean
you can film like a whole bunch of [ __ ]
but if you don't know how to cut it
together
to make that story flow man it's just
not
i got high hopes for the new i got high
hopes for the new dune
i know a lot of people well don't i mean
don't get your hopes too far out that's
a good director it's not
it is that is a good it is and evidently
the dudes that [ __ ] were on the new
star wars
series you know the the guy who played
finn and po they
made some comments on because the guy i
think who paid
uh pau is in it i believe yeah
he's in it yeah yeah i think he was
right and evidently you know he really
did that dude's name oh [ __ ] yeah he he
released i'll remember a second some
[ __ ] got released some photographs of
the costumes that they had some of the
scenes and [ __ ] the guy who played
finn was just [ __ ] and he's like
damn i wish we would have had that for
for star wars and
because they bust on star wars [ __ ] i
don't know if you know that but [ __ ]
those two dudes
[ __ ] are very very disappointed with
[ __ ] how the star wars turned out
and just like evidently what the actors
are saying
to each other this new dune is going to
be
bad ass well i mean the story is there
and i think the problem
like i said we talked about this on the
on the you know review that we did
the problem was that one david lynch
wasn't super
into like the source material like he
did the best he could and it was like
weird and he's
he does that but it's like he didn't get
final cut like they kept [ __ ] with
him about it he just had a miserable
experience
and then it just seemed like it didn't
have enough time
to br so i think like making it into a
series is really like the best thing you
can do i mean trying to cram all of that
[ __ ] into like a two or even a two and a
half hour movie that is just not gonna
fly it's you know what i mean
it's like i don't think anybody could do
it yeah that's right uh jaws and star
wars was saved during edit that's what i
mean i think all
movies i think the editor is really he's
kind of the final person
yeah you know before it goes out into
the world it's like well this could be
could be really really awesome or it
could be really really [ __ ] but i think
like
well i mean you know dependent obviously
you have to have something to work with
like as far as the footage goes
but i mean if you have like a whole
bunch of footage
an editor can make a good movie out of
it star wars a new hope was
way ahead of its time when it came out
it was independent film it [ __ ]
it was excellent me back in 77 as an
eight-year-old watching it i [ __ ]
loved it
but really out of all those movies
there's only one of them that is [ __ ]
a masterpiece
and that's return of the jedi in its
original form before all the editing and
stuff
return of the jedi and then i think
that's because [ __ ] are you sure
aren't you sure like empire strikes back
excuse me yeah i was gonna turn to the
jedi
and the reason why empire strikes back
is uh
so good is because lucas had the least
amount to do with it
the guy's a director well as we said
before he's a good idea guys he's not a
good director he's just
not a good like getting the [ __ ] done
guy that's all it's
you know not everybody could be good
he's not a good director and he's not a
very good screenwriter he can't write
[ __ ] dialogue real well he's just
he's a he's the guy you want on a team
to come up with this [ __ ] but you don't
want him to have full creative control
over
who says what and when and [ __ ] the
edit of the movie
star wars was the very first one new
hope was a hit
because of edit and luck it had a lot to
do with it yeah
and his concept definitely you know
although a lot of the [ __ ] about the
movie was british it's
it's a british movie british guys did
yeah
almost the entire crew yeah and and they
should all the studio
and the look of the [ __ ] all the
robots and darth vader and the ships and
everything
british guys kind of ripped that off
from a french comic book called valerian
yeah uh if you look at the old which
they made a movie of that a couple years
ago and i couldn't sit through it
valerian terrible i have it
yeah about 10 minutes in i was like yeah
i'm not checking out
right this i wanted to like it but
it's just boring yeah i just cut i
couldn't
catch the way it couldn't get yeah
there's supposed to be some john carter
in his name john carter
there's a john carter movie that came
out which is kind of like
kind of like conan on mars i'd like to i
don't know if it's any good or not i
don't maybe you guys have seen it but
evidently the books were really good
yeah you ever heard of it i think it's
called john carter something rather
well i know that's i can't remember i
know that's a thing but i don't know if
it's the same thing that you're talking
about
yeah somebody said y'all should cover
richard chase john carter of mars yeah
we did didn't we we did richard chase on
vampire killers
yeah we did richard yeah we did a show
called vampire killers and i'm pretty
sure we talked about richard chase on
there so you know just one yeah is john
carter from mars any good
it i'll read it if it's any good i mean
it's kind of hard to do a sci-fi movie
nowadays because everything's cg and cg
is usually handled pretty shitty
they all it loses all flavor
yeah it does it's just well everything
kind of looks at all exactly
the same it all kind of looks samey the
the best cg the best handling of cg i've
ever seen was the new blade runner
was it 20 48 2049 20 49 that cg looked
[ __ ]
fantastic because it felt like i was in
a location
yeah you know yeah they did a really
good job man yeah
i still love that man i just hope we
like watch that like
i just hope dune [ __ ] is as good as
that yeah
yeah uh the same person also asked
what's the voices it's a
20 20 horror movie that is on to be
right now it's psychological horror
if that's your thing oh so nobody's
actually seen the john carter movie i
just didn't know if it was any good
because i think
i think disney did a version of it it
flopped he said it was written by edgar
rice burroughs
the same guy that wrote tarzan that's
who wrote the books yeah
but there's a movie came out a couple
years ago and i think it's a disney
movie
i don't remember if disney's i remember
that movie coming out but i didn't see
it it [ __ ] bombed it flopped nobody
went to go see it
but i don't know if it's a bad movie
sometimes that happens yeah i mean like
i said it's not always because sometimes
i go see a movie and be like man i love
that and then like people are like man
there's no well there's no name
recognition like what's the what's it
john carter it sounds [ __ ] boring
it does it is a very it sounds very
boring i mean if it was me i know that's
kind of what the book was called but if
it was me i
changed the name but a native something
else a real exciting name and then and
the sub
underneath it the subtitle of it would
have been john carter from mars or
something like that
yeah see that probably would have been
the best yeah because yeah it does it
definitely does need like uh
no you know an exciting title or an
intriguing title or something
like oh i wonder what that is you know
what i mean you need kind of a title and
they're never going to be able to do a
conan right that's just
that they don't have the writing skills
in hollywood anymore
if there's going to be a conan it's
going gonna have to be some kind of a
of a [ __ ] um
uh what do you call it like an
independent film with a lot of good
talent
and it's gonna have to look like a
frankfurzetta panty kind of like it
should look like 300
you'll be like the 300 but it should be
like like something out of rosetta
yeah that was my idea that would be cool
actually that's how it should look
it should look like a moving frank
frazetta painting
but it's live action just that's just
the cg should look
and it should just be [ __ ] totally
brutal it should be rated r
b people cutting people's heads off with
axes and fighting [ __ ] minds
kind of like that old like that that
well it's not old but that series that
the sp
it was spartacus right or yeah whatever
the [ __ ] it was
i'm thinking it should be something
straight out of heavy metal magazine and
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
pretty damn brutal
yeah i think that would be cool that's
what it should be
yeah i don't know if they can do it
anymore though all right we got to shut
it down
yeah we kind of we kind of went off on a
tangent like we usually do
but yeah like i said i mean if you're
into
kind of one location psychological
horror like are these people crazy is
there paranormal [ __ ] going on is there
something more prosaic going on we don't
really know and i'm not gonna really
tell you
but this is actually a pretty good movie
it's called the voices um like i said
don't confuse it with uh you know
there's also
a horror comedy called the voices that
has ryan reynolds in it that came out in
2014 which is also very good but it's
not the same uh type of thing at all but
yeah this is on uh
to be for free yeah so
if you want to watch it you certainly
may yeah if you want sure it's me or
just remember to send us a private
message we'll work it out yeah just send
me a private message what your
what your uh address and your size yeah
what model you want and which uh
logo you want like i said we got the we
got the just the logo one with the
little skull we got the
when you wait we got a 13 o'clock one
and we have well we have these ones too
like the old like
friday the 13th poster looking like yes
i think we still have the screen for
that
no i don't think so i think oh you don't
have a screen i got rid of it i mean i
could shoot another one but yeah
all right so uh we will probably next
time the live stream will probably be
saturday for the regular episode
so uh but i'll but tomorrow witching
hour will go up and then movie
retrospective will go up on friday so
there'll be some content for you guys to
watch
uh so i guess we will talk to you later
thanks for stopping by as usual
and uh we'll see you next time bye